thank you
[Music]
we know with certainty that fossil fuels
need to be phased out it could have been
done slowly but now we are running
against time so we have a very
complicated relationship with fossil
fuels at the moment it's like your ex
partner you want to get rid of them but
they stick around
[Music]
while the need to get off fossil fuels
is straightforward and Urgent the
pathway to doing it equitably is
anything but what are the viable
Pathways to a clean and safe future and
how do we collectively navigate this
transition we know that credible people
disagree in some pretty fundamental ways
on this topic the core of the climate
challenge recently we brought together
experts activists and leading voices in
the climate space to speak listen and
work together as we figure out how to
make progress despite our differences we
cannot emit more than 500 gigatons of
CO2 between 2020 and 2050. the fossil
fuel industry itself is also Powerhouse
of fairy tales we often speak with the
acceptance of this tautology that no
country has ever developed without the
use of fossil fuels but that's not the
whole truth right the whole truth is
that no country has developed without
the use of fossil fuels yet so how can
the U.S and Europe be smarter about
ending energy poverty and addressing
climate change if local Enterprise had
access to long-term low-cost financing
like their counterparts in other regions
of the world can simply take for granted
then Africa's Clean Energy Future would
build itself
what we don't want to lose is that
ultimately there are people at the heart
of systems and systems change will
sometimes fail just because two folks
cannot get along with each other we need
people to get on board and I fight for
climate Justice and this means getting
people on board with that
I've never spoken to each other before
and that have always disagreed what
would we do now if we believed we'd
succeed Nelson Mandela famously said it
always seems impossible until it is done
and I love that phrase
[Music]